welcome to our planning committee
meeting today
we have two applications to consider
along with the report on planning
appeals i'm happy with this and intend
to take the business in order in which
they're set out on the agenda
item one apologies for absence
uh yes thank you chair uh apologies have
been received from councillor armitage
who's been subsequently uh substituted
by councillor piancliff and apologies
have also been received from councillor
l hartzon thank you chair thank you
item 2 declarations of interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
pecuniary interest and or other
interests
not already on their register of
interest
in any item on the agenda and withdraw
from the meeting at the appropriate time
do any members have any interest to
declare
none have been received here
moving on to item three
minutes of the last meeting
we now have the minutes of our meeting
held on tuesday the 28th of june 2022
are we happy that they are a correct
record
thank you thank you all those in favor
any against
any abstentions
like this
the main business this afternoon
before we start i would like the clerk
to explain for the benefit of members
speakers and those watching on youtube
how we will deal with them
thank you chair
this is the procedure for considering
the applications this afternoon
the chair will introduce the
applications
as there's no late representations
report
the planning officer will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs on the site
after this the chair will ask the
speakers to address the meeting
each of the speakers will have three
minutes to put forward their views
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes members of the committee will
have an opportunity to ask the speaker
questions
if necessary to clarify any points they
have made
when we have heard from all of the
speakers on an application
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate and determination by a vote
the votes will be taken by roll call
after a speaker has addressed the
committee and answered any questions
then they will be allowed to remain in
the chamber
but they will not be allowed to
participate further from this point
finally members this meeting is being
live streamed and recording will be
placed on the council's website
please note that others may choose to
copy it
thank you chair
thank you
in line with our normal practices i am
going to ask the planning officers to
tell us about any late comments and to
give a brief presentation showing any
photos and plans of the site
i will allow the officers to complete
the presentation consequently members
could you please reserve any points of
order or questions about the process to
the end thank you
so much just for clarification this is
on the clay cross application yes yes
thank you
so our first application this afternoon
is any d forward slash 22 4
0 0 5 1 9 slash fl clay cross
emily i believe you're leading this
good afternoon thank you chair my first
confirm that no late representations
have been received on this application
in terms of detailing the application is
for the retention of a change of use the
commercial unit to a pet crematorium
with associated flu warehousing and
offices at 2e 2f churchview clay cross
excuse me could you speak a bit closer
to the microphone
members of planning committee attended a
virtual site visit yesterday where we
saw a range of photos of the site the
main consideration for members is the
principle of the change of use there are
no technical issues with the application
next slide please
thank you
the first slide illustrates the site
shaded in orange to the center of the
screen the site is located between the
coney green road to the west and railway
line to the east the site is situated
within the defined settlement
development limit of clay cross and is
also designated as a principal
employment area
the red line plan denotes the pass of
land subjective application uh the
building is situated within a complex of
eight business units known as church
view business park
have the next
thank one here we've got a slide showing
the elevation and floor plan the
application building is highlighted in
red
the only external alteration proposed
relates to the flue which is situated on
the northwest facing rear elevation this
measures the maximum dimensions of 2
meters high by 22.5 centimeters wide and
is finished in a matte gray color
thank you
here we have a more detailed floor plan
unit 2e to the left will probably be
used as a warehouse to store items
associated with the business
such as urns for ashes and other
keepsakes into the rear of the unit is a
cold store
the right hand part of the building is
unit 2f and features an office area
where the administration side of the
business will be taken
with a small assisted kitchen and toilet
facilities to the rear um is the pet 200
cremator
thank you
the next few sides are key photos taken
from committee site visit which members
attended yesterday included these as a
refresher for members this first photo
shows the two units subject to the
application to the left you have the
roller shutter and personal door which
serves the warehouse side to the
business and to the right you've got the
main entrance which is the office side
of the business and just to the front
you've got the designated parking
next one thank you
this last photo is taken from koenig
green road and shows the flu which is
situated on the rear elevation of the
building
that concludes the presentation thank
you chair
thank you
i will now invite the speakers to
address the committee we have two
speakers both in support of the
application they are richard slack the
applicant and charlotte state and the
agent
as the clerk explained they will each
have three minutes to get over their
points they will be informed when 30
seconds remain
as members you can ask them to clarify
any matters that have been raised but
remember your question should only
relate to the points which have already
been made
i would like now to our first feature
speaker mr richard slap the applicant to
come and address the committee
can you please confirm that this is your
name and that you understand the process
i do and it is sorry
have three minutes when you're ready my
name is richard and my business partner
nick is on holiday
or he would be here too we're both pet
lovers with two dogs each our local vets
are fantastic at delivering a service to
poorly pets
but they're not designed to deliver
afterlife services after they have
deceased pets are stored impact freezers
collected once a week by corporate
crematorium which for most part is out
of the region and not returned for
nearly two weeks without any
communication
all in all pretty undignified for the
pet owner and very undignified for the
deceased pet this is why we started
chesterfield pet crematorium to deliver
a personal dignified and fast service to
the local area to offer only individual
cremations with cctv in the work area to
offer collection of pets and delivery of
ashes within a 24-hour turnaround if
required to give local residents a
choice of afterlife service versus the
service offered by vets still offering a
cost-effective service and let's take a
large referral fee of about a hundred
pound per pet for organizing cremations
we're all about delivering a quality
local service to the pet lovers of north
east derbyshire all types of pets are
treated with equal respect
the next nearest similar service has
just moved from sutton in asheville to
warsaw and they received planning
permission for two cremator machines
like ours to be cited in their domestic
garage at home
we've provided information about our
site search in the application we've
considered available properties on the
high street commercial premises and also
our own residential homes
as india as an industrial unit was a
natural choice for the business and this
was confirmed as appropriate by the
environmental health officer the
cremation process itself is performed by
a deferred approved machine which is
energy efficient and re-burns smoke and
odours prior to its release
all you can see is an occasional heat
shimmer so no impact on our neighbors
this is not a dirty industrial process
the machine itself only takes up
approximately one percent of the floor
space the unit
the remainder of the space is our
officers and stocks of earned and other
memorials that families can choose from
our website
nick and i and northeast object
residents trying to provide a service to
pet lovers at a time when they are
grieving whilst we can't stop
undignified afterlife processes that
vets have to undertake we can at least
offer local residents a choice
if a business unit at coney green isn't
appropriate we're not sure where we're
supposed to operate
we ask please
to support our proposal thank you
thank you are there any questions
councillor hancock
thank you chair um just one question so
just to clarify cos one thing that you
said i think is is quite um significant
in the report that we've got i know clay
cross parish council raised a concern
about um potential fumes
my understanding from what you've just
said is that that totally isn't actually
a factor at all that it doesn't it's
because it's deferred approved and it it
burns under a certain kilogram weight
um it's classed as clean burn technology
so it heats the secondary chamber up to
850 degrees
um so any fumes or smoke that pass
through that are burnt so you just
literally get a heat shimmer so if you
used to stand with your head on top of
the flue you wouldn't smell anything
councillor cooper
thank you chad
um
it's slack um
on that industrial unit are there any
other
um businesses that produce any any
smells or
anything like that or smoke i'm just i'm
just curious to know
yeah so the the building behind us is a
big welding company a fabrication
company so they've got and they're
blowing fumes after the roof constantly
opposite that there's a big paint
spraying um car restoration garage that
they've got the big paint
um
from the paint
um booths that all the fumes come out so
yeah there we are
are there any further out today earlier
thank you chad
this uh i've received some pictures
i believe from charlotte
is this is this facility just for small
pets
i mean people keep horses and donkeys
and camels and
god knows what nowadays yeah it's not
for camels or horses it's for small it
is for donkeys yeah
if you're cutting off now we cannot we
only do domestic pets
right um throws hamsters guinea pigs
right up to um a great dane yeah but not
it's not equine it's not what we're
looking at doing and david's already
answered my question on smells thanks
very much thanks
are there any further questions
counselor and clip
can i just ask you
when someone comes along and brings
their pet to be cremated um
is this
fired up every day
or is there a certain days when you
actually cremate
do you store them or
what what actually happens if we've got
a cold store should we need it but the
the plan is to cremate every day because
for the efficiency of the appliance once
it's up to temperature
by keep feeding it
further animals it is more efficient
than it would be to fire it up from cold
cremate one animal shut it down and then
start it again tomorrow so the plan is
it's designed to use six to seven uh or
to cremate a maximum of six to seven
pets per day
all right thank you
councillor elliot oh no he's shaking his
head i was going to ask about that it
does state in the report about seven
animals chair and i was gonna ask about
that so if you're saying you're gonna
get this thing up to temperature and
make it more efficient
surely you'll be doing more than seven a
day
no because
how long does it take per it depends on
the on the pet so
the
cremator is designed to put your largest
fattest pet in first because the
cremator is designed to use the
to use the fats of the animal as a fuel
so once a large animal goes in it uses
the animal as the fuel and shuts all the
burners off
um so then when it's up to temperature
imagine like a kiln for a pottery uh
once it's up to temperature it's ideal
to keep it at that temperature because
it's using a lot less fuel so it's a lot
more efficient so you put your largest
animal in at the beginning and at the
end of the day you would put your
smallest animal because it's up to
temperature and it's actually
it's gone um
when we say a large animal a 60 kilogram
dog
could take anything up to three hours so
and six to seven we wouldn't be doing
six to seven sixty kilogram dogs
thanks very much mr smith thank you
thanks jeff councillor cooper then
councillor anchor
um
how many people will be employed in this
in this
business initially there's going to be
two people but we are looking
um
to take that up to four and a half
possibly five people um we can't be
working on the cremator collecting pets
and working in the in the office at the
same time so we're hoping to be up four
and a half to five people
just out of interest
if i was to bring my and my dog say to
be cremated and i want the ashes of my
pet back
how do you separate them is there a time
limit
how
how do you deal with that so
we only offer individual cremations
we're not a production line we don't
want to offer the service where we're
putting multiple pets in at one time
so one peck will go into the cremator
when the pet is cremated
we have to wait for a certain
temperature before we can open the front
door of it because it burns at 850
degrees so nobody wants to be standing
in front of that door until it cools
down to 350 degrees
then we've got a machine that we can
rake the ash out
it's a flat smooth surface in the bottom
we've got a fireproof brush
metal brush that every little piece of
ash comes out of it
and then
once it's cooled down further then we
can put the new pet in and then we start
the process again
we put cctv cameras up pointing at the
cremator as well so if anybody wants to
challenge us and say
have you put two pets in we can say well
no we can prove it to you
thank you
councillor liggett then i think we'll
round it up yeah i was just asking asked
about the cold store actually because i
was more concerned about the smells
beforehand because i was a veterinary
nurse
um
your coal store doesn't look very big is
that just because it doesn't
it's uh the plan is is only to store
that is more of an emergency so if
we needed if we had an influx of animals
coming in one day and we couldn't
cremate them all in the same day then at
least we can put them in the cold store
overnight
for the next day but the plan is not to
have it stacked full of animals it's
it's
we don't want to be a production line we
don't believe we're gonna get
that influx it's just as emergency
should we need it or if somebody
pets don't pass away in office hours
no so if somebody phones us at
11 o'clock at night and they've got
nowhere to store the pet themselves we
can then put the pet in our cold store
just overnight and then we can
start the cremation the next day
thank you if you'd like to take a seat
next speaker is charlotte stanton
three minutes when you're ready
charlotte
thank you some of the things i'm going
to say you've been talking about so
apologies for any repetition
um this property is in the heart of the
coney green employment area where as you
know the council encourages new
businesses planning permission is only
required because of the technicality as
the cremation side of the business does
not fit neatly into the business use
classes
when nick and richard first got in touch
with me my initial reaction was like the
parish council one of concern about
impacts however on seeing the cremator
and discussing the business all my
concerns were addressed
the cremator has the appearance of a
clay kiln at school it is small and sits
in the corner of the industrial unit
we had hoped to show some photos that
were submitted with the application
which are these
which i did email at today and hopefully
some of you have seen those that one in
particular just shows the sort of scale
of of the kill which i think is helpful
sorry the cremator which looks like a
kill
the cremator itself is 2.3 meters by 1.1
meters or seven foot six by three put
three foot seven in old money
the majority of the business is about
the personal and dignified service the
company delivers there is no similar
business in north east derbyshire and
possibly even the whole of the county
at the moment a personal and dignified
local cremation just isn't an option to
those who sadly lose their pets
your planning officers have confirmed
8.14 that there are no objections to the
business on the grounds of design or
visual impact
at 8.17 it is confirmed that the scheme
would not have overriding or harmful
impacts on any residential or commercial
properties in the area
there have been no local objections
there are no objections on flood risk
drainage or highway grounds
we have submitted technical detailed
information as you've heard on noise and
emissions and the environmental health
officer has raised no objections
as richard explained two of these
creators are operating successfully from
a domestic garage in warsaw
the reason for refusal is not logical in
this case it is based on a very strict
policy interpretation of appropriate
business users which does not occur in
my opinion with the national planning
policies which seek to encourage all
types of business
it also fails to acknowledge that other
sewer generous users such as motor
seeker uk have been granted by the
council in this area
it is rare for me to visit a client
business and be so impressed by the
level of care for their customers they
offer the same caring service to the
families of all types of family pets
having studied the available options i
honestly don't think there's a more
appropriate location
granting this business would not harm
your employment land supply by would it
it provides northeast derbyshire with an
important and caring local business
ensures the business unit remains
occupied and delivers employment thank
you
are there any questions
councillor foster
thank you chair uh
thank you for that uh miss stanton um my
question is about you uh our policy wc2
uh we've heard lots about uh the
services that are provided the fumes uh
pet storage
uh cold storage but i don't think any of
that's been uh been questioned
uh i think the real issue here is as it
says in the report uh it's this wc2 and
you takes a technicality
uh do you want to expand more on that
it's it's
that you think it's just a technic
technicality and it's not logical
so just from that point no longer that's
the only point i'm considering out of
all of this
yeah and that's what the reason refusal
um sorry the reason for refusal um
relates to
the
thank you
the issue is that planning permission is
needed because it doesn't fit into a b
use category the policy is very strictly
restricting
business
use in this area to be uses and some
e-uses as well under the new use classes
so we're in a situation where
my clients say well
where are we supposed to go
because most people wouldn't ideally
want it operating in a domestic garage
most people wouldn't ideally want it
operating in a high street
um
so they're in a situation where an
employment area seems the most logical
um we appreciate that there's some
distinction in the local plan between
in theory cleaner business
areas under wc2
and the general industrial areas which
in theory it could go in but that we
haven't been able to find a suitable
location in a general employment area
and the fact is this business wouldn't
do any harm in the wc2
so the reason that wc2 is trying to
restrict uses
is so that it's not preventing or
causing problems for other businesses
there
which it wouldn't be doing
so the purpose of you've got to look
beyond what the wording of the policy
says in terms of the b classes and say
what is the purpose of this policy the
purpose of this policy is
to decide whether or not this business
is acceptable in this location
and we believe we've demonstrated that
it is
i hope that explains i'm sorry i've got
a bit around the houses there
any other questions
no uh council hancock
thank you joe just just one it's only
only a quickie obviously
we've been talking about what this this
pulse is designed for you've been to the
site in your opinion if it wasn't used
for something else would it actually be
employing any more people than what they
suspect that what they're anticipating
well we don't know the answer to that is
the honest answer um
another business may well move in there
but it had stood vacant it was available
to lease so quite honestly my clients
had no idea that their business wasn't a
business use that would be welcomed in
that location
they're not huge units now absolutely
and very often used for a significant
amount of warehousing which as you know
doesn't have a very high number of
employees per per square meter
any other questions can australia
charlotte
this probably isn't quite up your street
but i want to go back to emissions and
smells because
and i will ask this when when we open
the floor to the officers but
what i want to know is
if there's nothing comes out of this
chimney this this flu that is
either odorous or
or can cause any harm it can't for me be
any different to the spray bay opposite
or or the smoke and stuff coming out of
the welding shop
so can you tell me how the emissions are
monitored and what they monitored for
on this particular float
it's essentially heat that's coming out
of the flue
um
i can confirm that it
in many ways is no different to those
other businesses although actually it's
better because those are businesses you
can smell and you are aware of the
operations going on and they are noisy
um the environment the key point i think
for you is that the environmental health
officer has raised an objection
the cremator
is deferred approved so these are
standard units that can go in and have
been
tested and have been confirmed as
complying with the relevant legislation
in terms of their emissions and their
noise so there
there's a certificate there literally in
the office that i've seen that confirms
that that cremator meets those
requirements so there isn't the
necessity to monitor each one because as
long as they're operated as they're
supposed to be operated and why wouldn't
they be then they comply with the the
requirements of the regulations
thank you thank you chair
any further questions
thank you sean thank you
moving on we now have the opportunity to
put questions to the offices about the
application again i would like to keep
this part about proceedings focused on
getting clarity about any points you're
not sure of
once we have done this we can then have
our discussion about the application
based on all what we have heard and read
i would be grateful if you could not
move any motions at this stage
let's wait until we've all had a chance
to make our own assessment
counselor elliot
thank you chair my question
that i've just asked is to richard and
the officers um
if this was a brick kiln or a pottery
kiln or or um
an exhaust that takes the emissions away
from a car workshop or a mlt testing
station
would that be acceptable in this
position as opposed to a pet cram
[Music]
i think the the point
the question you make is is whether
any um use that is creating some sort of
a mission would be acceptable on on this
site is that
i think the thing is richard if there's
a spray bay opposite that's taking fumes
out of the workshop or there's a welding
facility that's welding all day and
taking the smoke and extracting out into
the atmosphere and this particular
let's call it a
a kiln
if this particular facility
is not presenting any odor and just heat
where is the issue or can you can you
tell me the difference between
the spray bay and the welding shop and
the difference between this that emits
just heat
as opposed to anything you know no
nauseous or noxious
i think if you look on on page 14 of the
site location plan you'll see that
there's the the church view business
part with its own um uh access
and and
that's that business mark is for
it is intended in the local plan to be
for because clean uh research
development like industrial uses
the i think the question
two questions sequentially um
that the committee needs to consider in
the next phase of the um uh of the
meeting really is
um
does it want to keep
this business park as being for those
those clean uses
and secondly
that
um if it does
does this particular use
harm that at all and we're not taking
any uh any um we're not questioning
environmental health at all to say that
it's fine and indeed we're with modern
day
emissions controls we wouldn't expect
that this you know this to actually be
creating anything which is uh which is
harmful to to the air because
environment agency environmental health
a couple of those things uh um at
nauseam
so
we don't see that particular um
uh
odor or smoke coming from there
um
we don't imagine that's really going to
be a a big
big problem in itself
the
the the fact
that this is a
a type of use that doesn't have a used
class
and therefore doesn't fit into the type
of abuses that have been anticipated
so so the question as i go back to the
to the sequential questions is
does the committee want to keep this
business park for the types of uses that
have been uh identified in the plan for
research development for
light industrial and such like
um and if it does does this use cause a
harm to that for future occupiers maybe
thinking actually i don't want to go
there
because there's a pep commentary in
there or anything like that so it's a
fairly simple question or series of
questions to to ask as to whether or not
this is something that should
uh support or not support
thank you um i'm just going to pick up
on your um on on what you said about
clean users you use those word clean
users well surely if this is monitored
and there's no smoke coming out of this
chimney as we've heard it's just heat
then surely it is a clean use facility
much so like the
welding shop and the spray bay
is that is that i'm just trying to
understand the correlation between
the the businesses and where we would uh
turf this out on wc2 but we don't on
emissions from a spray bay or
a welding shop
that's that's what i'm after from you if
that's possible and and as i said i
think as far as this particular use is
concerned obviously one we need to uh to
concentrate on is that uh
we have no issue with um
environmental health advice that
there are suitable controls for
emissions to to actually make sure that
we're not seeing plumes of smoke coming
out or
a
sickening or
bad smell coming from there
then
my my question there is is purely and
solely about if this if this uh or if
this doesn't fit in what we consider
that are those why users is that because
that's an oversight from
us or
or did we ought to see if this does fit
in with that in that bracket
because all i'm looking for is how we've
arrived at refusal and i can understand
where you're coming from because it
doesn't it's not stated in what we state
as a light industrial use but all i can
see is that's the only reason
yes indeed and i think the the fact that
as i say this
a crematorium doesn't
have a particular used class that would
then fit in with the policy
it is a what we call a sewer generous
use which means it's a a use without a
particular particular category and so
that is why it is um something which
doesn't fit in fairly and squarely with
this policy
thank you thank you chair thank you
councillor hall
yeah thank you yeah what i was going to
ask i mean we've been
told about other industrial units nearby
like the
uh
car workshop paint workshop and welding
are they on other um
other part other industrial estates then
do you know
oh
sorry do you want me to repeat that
it was for richard
yeah
i think as i say on if you look on page
14
yeah you'll see
the church view business part
yeah i think that the uh the units that
have been mentioned by um the the
applicant in the presentation are the
units behind there
um
which is not part of the church view
um business part
okay the church view business park has
its own discrete access and
an entrance there
the
the units behind coming from
an access from a different location
thank you just to check in
that's
whether that is um uh
whether the
um unit
has been referred to as
giving out fumes is actually part
of the same policy allocation
they were just whilst they're checking
i've got uh councillor foster
councillor jones and councillor cooper
take them in that order uh thank you
chair uh yeah a question to mr purcell
uh
a lot of uh
what i was going to ask council
elliott's uh asked already but going to
policy uh wc2
and it doesn't say light industrial
which i'll happily have this confirmed
it says general industrial and v8
storage distribution and industrial and
research so this uh application for this
for this use fits none of those
then we go on to page 91 of the
local plan and it says on two where it
doesn't fit one of those classes it'll
only be permitted where the proposed use
and then it says amb as i'm sure we've
all read and silly to the main use on
that site so it doesn't follow policy
there
and it would not prejudice the future
functional viability of employment uses
on the site so i'd like to explore that
a little uh
from an officer perspective how this
might um
prejudice the viability of employment
uses on the site i understand the clean
uses and i understand i think the to me
it sounds like i'm getting to my opinion
here it's not a statement but it sounds
like the spray booth and the other uh
businesses it's a bit of a red herrings
it's not actually on this side that's
what it sounds like from what i've heard
so what i'm concerned about is
is the clean user statement on uh church
view business park and how if we if we
were minded to go against officers
recommendations here
how what could happen uh to this area
how could it affect the viability of
employment uses on this particular site
if that's if that's clear
thank you
it's it's very difficult to um
today how it could affect the vibe
viability it's really a case of if
if someone was coming forward looking
for uh sites on a clean business part
for
research development uses or for for
other uh uses that um
uh require
um
clean and quiet environments
would
when they see this use
would they think actually i think i'd
prefer to go somewhere else or would
they think actually
um i can't see any smoke or
fumes coming out from there
you know it's not really going to affect
us and i think it's so it's it's
uh
the question is how do people who are um
relocating and setting up businesses
make those make those decisions
and uh
is that something that would uh affect
their um
uh their decision making and think well
actually there wasn't anywhere in clay
cross for us to have clean uses um or
this type of business our type of
business and and they look to go
elsewhere and so it's it's uh i'm sorry
to give us a very quick answer like that
but it's it's really how the business
people make their decisions about
location
yeah if i come back on that so so
suppose what i'm looking for is an
understanding of why we as a council and
as a planning authority uh set these
clean area clean uses areas out of what
they're actually for so it's so i've got
an understanding and i suppose the
committee's got an understanding it's
not that we just don't want to stop a
business providing employment but we've
got a we've got a duty to provide these
areas for other types of clean
businesses
so
it's and what i've wanted to move away
from is what other business is doing in
nearby areas and the service it provides
we've got the policy for a reason so
it's that policy and why it's there and
what the council has needed that policy
it's that uh explanation uh i'd like
clarity on please
yes it is and when you uh first drive in
or walk into church view business park
straight ahead of you as you'll see is
there's a
a a digital um business and and that
sort of starts to separate
that you would expect to see elsewhere
in the in the state
thank you and councillor jones
yeah it's um really i think it's
probably been answered but i was
concerned about the fact that
um it's a service business in debt we're
providing a service
for people so that so they can
give their pets a dignified cremation
but
i believe that there was other sites
that were setting out
in missions but there isn't is that on
that particular
um area of development they're all clean
and but a lot of those that are in the
area
are still service rather than if you
have in your car sprayed as an
individual that's a service you're not
really manufacturing something that's
for everybody isn't it
so as chances work out when do you
decide if it's
a service or whether it's fits in
because it's developing something
than something to me
you know i i understand the point you're
making i think the um
the way that use classes are um
organized
is looking at what are the um the
effects of a particular uh use and yes
they have to make generalizations uh um
about these and yes there may be some
exceptions
but um in general the um situation
would be that uh this type of use
is not the type of use that
the when we set this policy that this
policy would would have in mind
yeah thank you
councillor cooper
and just
uh councillor foster asked really the
question i was going to ask but
supplementary on top of that is
uh on on this particular part of the
site then
how many how many units are currently
used or or
on the other side is how many are
currently empty just just out of
curiosity
um i i don't have that information at
the moment no i'm sorry
are there any further questions
counselor hancock
thank you chair it's it's kind of i
think following on from mark's throat a
bit
um
obviously
we've got this policy which is in place
the evidence that we have from defra and
from the um from our own environmental
health team is that this business is
clean
however one defining it is a clean
business
the bit that i'm i'm concerned about
here
is uh given what we're told in
99.999
of planning cases is that we shouldn't
be going down the roads of speculation
but i feel that you're almost trying to
draw us down that road because we we're
saying
potentially refuse this because it may
put off other businesses in the future
because it may not be clean but the
evidence that we have is that it is
clean
but we're still being drawn down this
speculation route so i'm really wanting
you to clarify for us
what we should be taking from this
well
i think every
local plan up and down the country will
have um
business park type uses identified for
for for clean research and development
office type
businesses
yes there will be some
other elements that are um
other uses that would be uh that can fit
comfortably next to those uses
and
and those are generally some prestigious
um uh uses that uh have some sort of
symbiotic relationship with each other
and they
they feed off each other you know
like any sort of
uh
business park or a manufacturing park or
whatever those have
they build up relationships between each
other and and help each other to
support each other
so
and then there are general industrial
uses where where you put um the uses
that do generate
fumes or dust or or things that can't um
be next to
these other cleaner uses
and so
you'll always have these sort of grades
of
employment sites across any any district
and as
i said really at the start
the main question here is does the
council want to keep the the churchview
business park as focused on
on being clean
office or research development type uses
and if it does
does this particular
use
um
play against
that
objective or does it not harm that
objective and i think that's that's the
main question that you need to
have
ask yourselves and
come into a decision on this application
council foster then i think we'll round
it up and move on thank you chair um i
think you've already just covered some
of the
again uh some some other question was
going to put to you but uh if we look at
the the two principal uh look at the
employment areas we've got the principal
employment areas which is what we're
speaking about wc2 and we've got wc3
general employment areas where it would
be acceptable so i know so it'll be a
difficult question uh to answer but uh
best you can message if so uh
is there a general shortage of uh
general employment service wc3
units uh around the district because
when you look there's quite a list there
that we've got in the local plan for wc3
so do you see
the venus shortage of that
um
i don't know if at this point in time
um on some of the existing sites there
are um vacant units or vacant sites for
new units to be built on
um and then there are allocated sites
for uh for
um
general um
business as well
um
do we have any information about the
occupancy rates and vacancy rates of
other
so we
we don't have information about all the
um all the other vacancies that might be
elsewhere
thank you okay i think we've done the
questions going around around in circles
so i'd like to open the floor now to um
debate
before we move on to that i think i'd
like our clerk to remind us all about
the motions
yes thank you chair
please bear in mind members that a
motion must be moved and seconded before
a vote is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded
then the amendment will be voted on
first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reason for moving a motion against
officer recommendations
should comprise the relevant planning
issues and be supported by the evidence
as necessary
if a motion to reject offers a
recommendation false
or in other words it has not passed
that doesn't mean to say that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion
in favor of the recommendations or a
different course of action
this will be need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
now in terms of the timing of the
emotions they should be moved and
seconded after the committee has heard
read and discussed the evidence before
it
the chair will indicate when this point
has been reached
members will be reminded of this by the
clerk if they wish to propose a motion
before then
thank you chair
thank you councillor liggett
just a comment really um i've just had a
quick look at what businesses are on
there
and we've got a plant hire and two
builders
are they clusters clean
um that was one question and also or
comment and also
the only place i can think would really
object
is jackson's bakery
just down the road because they have it
now the cafe as well as a bakery and
they've put no objections in
now i would have thought it was going to
upset anybody it would be them
counselor and coke
thank you chair i kind of come back to
the point i i raised with richard the
the evidence is in front of us is that
it is clean we've been told that by
environmental health we've been told
that by defra and we've got to balance
evidence over speculation and there's
there's no nothing in front of us that
would say someone would refuse to go
there because there's a pet crematorium
there
so i i genuinely don't see any reason to
uh
to agree with officers recommendations
on this one in fact if i'm truthful
obviously that's a motion for later on
but
i i i fully support it if i'm honest
the floor is open for debate council
foster
thank you chair uh
contrary to what uh council hancock says
there's no evidence it's clean
all that's happened is nobody's objected
when you look at a death row registered
wood burning still for example which is
accepted in in this area a deafer area i
know they've got one they have to run 87
so they'll give off 13 fumes so there's
nowhere that says it's clean at all it
will give off some fumes regardless
that's why it's got a flu
so they've got different systems for
collecting ash and for collecting some
fumes but essentially any crematorium is
going to uh is going to give off some
fumes it doesn't say anywhere here how
much
but you'd expect it to be along those
those lines so you've said twice that
there's evidence there is no evidence
here at all to be told there's no
evidence at all that it's actually clean
there will be some uh fumes giving off
that's the first thing for me
is it true breathing yeah
yeah because we don't but we don't
breathe out like a crematorium john oh
she smoked perhaps
no there's no evidence um
uh
for myself i'm uh i've listened to what
the planning office is saying it seems
to revolve around
not the service not what the other
businesses are it's whether we as a
council want to keep this area for wc2
uh businesses for that appropriate sort
of business and not wc3 so when you look
at what we've got there's a full list in
the local plan of all the wc2 areas and
all the wc3 areas
and we put that in for a reason because
we want some of these areas to be for
clean businesses
if we're minded to ignore it we can do
and say okay we can put whatever
business you want in that area but it'll
mean doing it for me i know we don't
often create precedence we don't always
follow them but it will mean that
someone can come and say well there's
another wc2 area here we'll put another
one of these in another
type of business like this in that area
we got these in our in our local plan
for a reason that's what they're for the
guidelines are there and we've been
advised by officers so it's uh there is
no evidence that it's clean
uh or autistics dirty but it's a
crematorium um
that's my view on it without putting any
uh an emotion as such i think we've
covered everything there but for me it's
do we want to keep it as wc to this area
we either do we don't
thank you counselor pal
oh thank you chad
excuse me
i i think we're making this far more
complicated than it actually is
um
i have absolutely no issues with how mrs
like may or may not run his business and
i think it'll probably uh work when it
is in an appropriate place uh would be a
very successful one we should look with
that
but that's not the issue um
it is against
uh our policies now
as a committee we can't we can choose
which policies we're going to enact we
either have them or we don't
um and for that reason i disagree with
the agent who says it's a technicality
i don't think it's a technicality and in
8.9 it's very clear
uh would this undermine the strategic
approach of the council
and prejudice adversely the council's
policy on delivering commercial
development
on appropriate sites
we
have decided in the past that this site
um is therefore a reason and has a
purpose hence its wc2 and not wc3
so for me um i i cannot see an issue we
we have policies
um as i say we can't pick and choose
um and that's my view thank you chad
thank you
any further comment
counselor elliot
thanks chair um
yeah when we've been asking the
questions of the officers and i accept
what mark's looking at there as well
it is it is there in black and white but
council liggers already just said
there's a plantar place on there i
noticed i've walked around there a few
times there there are mechanics there
with stuff sat outside where they're
stripping oil and things so it's not
just you know if you if you consider the
wc2 is like you use of a i know richard
said there's a electronics or a computer
firm as you walk in but as you get
towards the back of the site it's not
all computers
that's where the plantar is and the
mechanics are and so on and so forth
so
you know i'm struggling with this one
and you know we i don't think we're
trying to make it fit in our criteria
it's just been stated that
nowhere is it sat about crematorium on
any of our paperwork
councillor hall then councillor foster
yeah i was just going to say i support
what council of foster and councillor
powell say at the end of the day if it's
a
an industrial estate that is specific to
the use it says w2 is it wc2 then that
that's what it's there for yeah we do
have
listed uh companies like where they say
um
[Music]
building or whatever developments and
things but they could just be the
officers for to build it building
companies it's not to say that they've
got piles of bricks and deliveries like
that there that could be just the office
for them
but as i say i do support what council
of foster and councillor powell said
thank you councillor foster
uh thank you chair uh to go back to the
last point that's been mentioned when we
look at builders planter and mechanics
and we're mentioning these as existing
businesses uh on on this on this uh this
estate if we look at what those actually
i don't know if anybody's looked at them
if you look at what the actual
definition is on the wc2
it does say general industrial use
so storage distribution users office and
industrial research development users so
it's a general industrial use builders
plant type mechanics would come under
that
so there's no difficulty that that's
what it's actually for
uh and they're all relatively clean what
you call clean because it is general
industrial and it's separate to uh
to wc wc3 so they would all those we've
mentioned would come under that existing
one
councillor hancock thank you chair i
think and total total respect to mark
and and councilor powell i think the key
thing which if i understand what richard
said correctly part of the problem here
is that this actually doesn't
comfortably fit in any of the groups
that we've got which is why it's in
front of us today
it's not an easy thing so we're we're
actually having to define is it
compatible with wc2 um and that that's
the question that
as i took from the conversation i have
with richard that's what we're actually
here to decide and it's whether whether
members feel
yes it does sit comfortably alongside
that or no it doesn't
counselor posture yeah thanks sorry to
come back but that's a bit of a red
herring it does fit in one you're not
saying it doesn't fit
no it fits quite clearly under wc3
well i'd ask the officer then does it
fit under wc3
richard
well i think as as i
said this question is does it
um
does the council want to keep this
business used for the purposes that it
was intended
and if it does
does this particular use um uh conflict
with that or not and and clearly
some members believe that it does and
some members believe that it doesn't
i mean
we've made our recommendation and given
the reasons why as stated in the in the
report
um the
the due and proper process now is for
members to decide whether they uh agree
to that and
i'm thought for something like this it
doesn't surprise me that there are these
different views and indeed that's
you know
apart from it being called to committee
committee
that sort of
is one of the reasons why it is for the
committee to make that decision
thank you councilman foster
sorry to come back again i'll answer my
own question and found it and it was
there 8.8 conversely policy wc3
identifies that those other employment
sites were the non-b class employment
generating users this one and
potentially including users such as a pr
pet crematorium would be acceptable so
it's there we've got in black and white
page 19 8.8 it would be acceptable in
the wc3 that's the only point i'm
tricking it is a debate and there's a
point i'm trying to make it's not that
the the other the other uses on this uh
on this site do come under wc2 and if
you read the policy they come under wc2
this one doesn't it fits on the wc3
and i think the question is much like
we've heard from the officer against
whether we want to keep this as a wc2
and allow a w or allow a wc3
type business into it
so i think that's fairly clear
[Music]
okay thank you i think we've done the
subject to do i say it to death
and i'm going to ask promotions
councillor hall
with officer's recommendation i'd like
to second that
motion then is to approve
the officer recommendations to refuse
the application
uh i should now take a roll culture if
that's okay
councillor and cliff
councillor cooper
councillor elliot
council of foster
for
councillor hall
for
councillor hancock
councillor liggett
against
councillor jones against
councillor powell
councillor roof
sorry councillor rouse
four
and councillor roth four
that's six four and five against
emotion as character thank you
we can move on to the second application
of the afternoon which is at high end
and that's ned
for slash 224
zero zero five zero eight four slash fl
which lands over two i believe
you chair just give me a second
okay um this is an application to remove
condition 12 which restricts the
permitted development rights the
dwelling is a former barn and workshop
which has been converted to a dwelling
and retains many many elements of its
former agricultural character
and lies within the conservation area
the application is recommended for
refusal in order for the council to
retain control and future alterations
ensuring the continued protection of the
building and the character of the
conservation area
grab the first slide please
thank you
this is an aerial photographer site with
the site in the center
it lies close to the junction with the
a61 and main road
and is accessed by a private drive to
the west of main road
this is a red line application site plan
again sharing the barn in the center of
the of the plan
this shows the extent to the high-end
conservation area with the barn located
within the northern part
in these areas there's statutory duty
place on the council to have regards to
preserving the conservation area
this is a photograph of the eastern
elevation of the building taken from
main road
uh this is a closer photo of the eastern
elevation
there was an appeal dismissed in 2019
for re-roofing with solar pv roofing
slates in the decision the inspector
stated that the natural slate roofs
contributed positively to the character
of the conservation area and that most
of the traditional buildings were in the
conservation area either have slate
roofs or stone tile roofs
this is a photo of the western elevation
of the building again in the previous
appeal the inspector commentator
commented that the building retains many
elements of its simple agricultural
character
uh it's the end of the presentation
thank you
and we've got one speaker i believe for
this afternoon so
this is fiona cooper
cropper sorry i do beg your pardon
you decide you have three minutes when
you're ready okay
good afternoon everyone i would like to
speak with reference to our application
to have mythic development rights
reinstated
we live in home conservation area
however houses in conservation areas
generally have permitted development
rights and in fact permitted development
rights
are already somewhat restricted in
conservation areas
you can't build a roof level for example
suggesting that the government's
attention is that permitted development
rights should apply in conservation
areas but in a more restricted way
our local councillor asked the planning
department for clarity on this matter
and our legal team advises that the case
officer's email to the counsellor
reveals that they are still not applying
the government's guidance
the council is simply not allowed to
take away permitted development rights
automatically
on all new conversions in order to
retain control over future development
they have no right to control over
future development
unless there are rare and unusual
circumstances about that site that
warrant the removal of rights
let's look at if our property in
question has rare or unusual
circumstances background
built in 1860 is an animal barn on
farmland
converted to a car garage and mechanics
workshop in late 1950s
sold in 1998 with permission for
conversion to dwelling planning rights
removed at this point
situation
sits well back from the main road partly
obscured by large trees
is it a list of building
no
does any aspect of the building or plot
have rare or unusual features
no
does it have any historical significance
no
therefore it does not fall into the
government's guidelines of warranting
removal of planning rights
the planning development manager in his
email to our local councillor refers to
control over the integrity of those
buildings
and
the contribution they make to the
character of the area in which they are
located
since making the conversion to dwelling
we have made many improvements to the
character of our property
using local and natural materials
wherever possible
adding traditional design double hope
fronted garages
we've made investment in local stone
masonry and pointing of exterior walls
we've removed non-native plants and
seconds remain
and installed a natural english hedgerow
in order to conserve not just the local
ecology and environment but also our
natural heritage national heritage
in short we have added and will continue
to add to the character of the building
and how it sits in the area
we are extremely aware of aesthetics
and we are sympathetic to
the natural area and how it how our
house
we ask you the planning committee to
look carefully at the evidence and make
an informed decision
thank you thank you are there any
questions for the speaker
no thank you very much like to take a
seat
we now have the opportunity to put
questions to the planning officer
if there are any
counsellor eliot
sorry phil
um
could you just um
give us a bit of a
heads up on this one because i when i
read the reason for refusal and it
relates to
um
the barn and the workshop
now it's being
converted into a
into a residential property
do that does that um pdl not come off
or or is the development rights on the
building whatever it is
or does it does it relate to what it was
the permissive development was removed
at the time of the application for for
the conversion um
and
um
the reason being um
is so that it we can preserve that
agricultural character
um for any future extension so that was
that was that was why it was removed
but yeah it was it was a former
agricultural barn then a workshop and it
was converted to a dwelling
but you can see from the photos that it
does
you can see that it was it looks like
above on conversion which is what it was
and that's where i'm at with it phil
really i mean for me they've kept it
looking aesthetically fabulous
absolutely it looks this beautiful
building yeah there's no doubt about
that
council hancock
thank you chair yeah it's just really to
follow up on what the applicant's
actually been saying about
the justification as to why the
permitted development's been removed
when it doesn't really seem to fit any
of those categories and if you can
expand on that well the british
development was removed
uh in
98 2000 when the application was granted
so yes it's long long but it was
a long time ago
um but i mean i set out in the report
and
we consider that um
given it's
that it's a former conversion it's in a
conservation area it's retained that
character that it's reasonable
and justified in this case to remove
continue moving the pd it's also backed
up to a degree by an inspector's
decision which
[Music]
made reference to the stone roofs and
the contribution in the natural
materials
yes the application was made because the
public development rights were no longer
there
are there any further questions whilst
i'm going through council power
just for clarity and that we understand
what the situation could be in the
future
if we were to remove
this condition
it would still be open to the applicant
to make any planning application should
they want to do any further work on the
building
if the application was
um
allowed and the british development was
reinstated you mean or no if sorry if we
say
we want to keep the condition up yeah
could at some future time the applicant
then say
well i've got an idea that i'd like to
do this i'll do that
it would still be open to them to apply
to the council to do that absolutely so
we're not we're not removing any right
no absolutely we're not saying you can't
accept the same property
thank you i just think that that's quite
an important element and any application
just needs to be made to the authority
and incidentally that will be a free
application there wouldn't have been an
application fee for that because it's a
free application when community
developments have been removed so
they're not hindered in that way
i have a quick question um
has there been any reason for it to be
removed stated you know that they want
it to be removed they got some building
work etc
there's nothing specific in the
application as to
why they want to get there's no sort of
project that they've said they've just
didn't care thank you
councillor foster uh thank you chad yeah
if i go to uh the last page of this uh
application reason for refusal that last
paragraph
uh we've just heard that uh any
uh
that that we that we'd still have to go
the the applicant would still have to if
they wanted uh
to build they'd still have to put a
planning application in
but here it says the removal of the
permitted development right so just to
explain to me for clarity remain
justified in order for the local
planning authority to retain control of
any additions to the building ensuring
the continued protection the
historic character
uh what more controls do we have if it's
left in place
if if it's left in place then the footer
development rights
are removed for extensions additions or
alterations to the roof alterations to
the roof
porches and curtis buildings so anything
under that umbrella would require an
application for the authority
any other questions
no thank you okay i'll open the floor
for debate if there is going to be one
looking at some very blank faces now
if not i'll move it that uh
it's open for the floor for motion
i'm quite happy to go with officers
recommendations
so the motion is to approve officer
recommendations
i'll now do the role
uh councillor and cliff
sorry was that for
councillor cooper
councillor elliot
council of foster for
councillor hall
for
councillor hancock
liggett four
councillor jones four
councillor powell
councillor rouse
thank you all very much we'll move to
item six late representations or we've
already done that so we can move on
item seven planning appeals lodged and
determined
over to you richard
i think the uh report um speaks to
itself for um appeals that we lodged the
pills that have been allowed and the
pills are being dismissed
um really it's a case of if there are
any specific questions about um any of
them that members have
are there any questions
no not only
oh sorry yeah are we on 1.2 appeals
allowed
yeah
if you could ask for a few more details
on that if you if you know some
please
yes and this one was um
it's an unusual sight actually in the um
home spiraled the gate conservation area
and it was for a
a small um
stables and tack room
which um the inspector concluded was um
was appropriate facilities for outdoor
sport recreation whereas it differed
from our our conclusion because
also on that site there was a stone
built stables that have now been
converted to a dwelling
i can i can find out more details if
if you wish
any other questions
no a final item is matters of urgency i
have no matter of urgency so i thank you
all very much for your attention this
afternoon
thank you
you